direction à présent la russie à la
veille de la fin du scrutin
constitutionnel vladimir poutine a pris
la parole tout à l'heure lors d'une
brève allocution télévisée le président
russe a appelé ses citoyens à garantir
la stabilité à la sécurité et la
prospérité du pays
le référendum devrait lui permettre de
renforcer son pouvoir vladimir poutine
pourrait être maintenu à son poste
jusqu'en 2036
les précisions sur place de notre
correspondant antoine crieront à la
veille du dernier jour de scrutin
concernant ces changements ces
amendements apportés à la constitution
russe vladimir poutine était chargé f à
200 km à l'ouest de moscou afin
d'inaugurer un monument en l'honneur des
combattants tombés lors de cette grande
bataille de la seconde guerre mondiale
elle en a profité au passage pour tenter
de mobiliser les électeurs qui ne se
sont pas encore rendus aux yeux nous
sommes face à un choix important il ne
s'agit pas seulement de normes
juridiques mais nous choisissons nous
faisons un choix vote pour le pays
le pays dans lesquelles nous avons
grandi pour plus de protection des
citoyens pour que les autorités puissent
rendre compte à la population dans un
pays dans lequel nous travaillons et que
nous voulons remettre à nos enfants et
je suis convaincu que chacun d'entre
vous participent à ce référendum en
pensant premièrement à ses proches
je remercie ceux qui ont déjà exprimé
leur choix et demain le 1er juillet sera
le jour principal du scrutin et je vous
demande chers amis de donner votre voix
chaque chaque voix chacun d'entre vous
est important
je vous remercie dans les faits les
changements à la constitution ont déjà
été adopté par le parlement
mais voilà avec ce scrutin vladimir
poutine cherche à donner une légitimité
populaire à cette réforme c'est la
raison pour laquelle ils se trouvent en
première ligne pour défendre ce vote et
pour convaincre les gens d'aller voter
et cela semble plutôt bien se présenter
d'après un sondage réalisé à la sortie
des urnes et publiés ce week-end pas
moins de trois votants sur quatre se
seraient prononcés en faveur des
amendements proposés voilà
reste encore toute cette journée du 1er
juillet la journée principal de ce vote
pour confirmer ou au contraire infirmer
cette tendance mais aussi pour connaître
le taux de participation final